the draft is in the books and now we're
left to figure out what just happened
Sims how you feel I'm good I'm glad that
would be good you change your mood here
yes I thought if you're gonna have to
get some cranberry juice for you over
here today that started out so what I
love though is we talked about this
before the draft no matter what happens
in the draft however the order people
get drafted right that determines
whether or not you were right or wrong
and you witness that with your son he
greeted me with he walked is so I got
home you know right at the end of the
third round cuz I landed in the second
round and I'm getting change and he runs
into my room and he goes Baker Mayfield
Josh Allen number seven to the Buffalo
Bills
you suck dad things that seems just
going home and feeling good about
himself right he's getting tested we
love Baker Mayfield what has it been
like oh by the way yeah on our YouTube
channel if you want to know what we
thought teams should do and then what
they did and how we reacted to it go to
the bleacher report YouTube channel and
pendrick has broken up pics one through
ten eleven through twenty twenty one
through thirty to each are about an hour
long go on a YouTube I'm gonna go on
later and and put like Chargers at this
time code so you can go right there
right but that's when like when the
Raiders are on the clock at 15 and we're
guessing could it be Harold Landry could
be anybody and then they pick Colton
Miller right you'll see our initial
reactions right there so go to bleacher
report YouTube everything's there that's
our big reaction will do more reacting
today yeah
but now that a few days have gone by and
you look at the giraffe right what are
some storylines that you're seeing that
you're surprised or big what are some
storylines that that not enough people
are talking about just you know top like
when you went to pro football talk this
much well I think that the first thing
just for me off the top of my head is
you know I felt like a wuss with my
grades and what a good guy know I did
but you know as I started like I had to
write my Power Rankings article
yesterday I started going through teams
and going through all the draft and I
wrote it down who they draft and
everything I just went damn a lot of
teams had a good
drops it was not a superstar drive but
talk about good players in the second
third fourth fifth around man it was
unbelievable
I think that's the one thing that jumped
out to me hey listen Baker may feel that
one is still one of the shoppers of the
draft to me certainly let's start there
okay let's start apologizing to Adam
Schefter okay because he came out with
the Baker thing and I was like what's
the point of this you're just trying to
help out the Browns and I
I said maybe chef ders been losing it I
take it back I should have never
questioned the Don you give him a ring
i'ma kiss the ring Adam Schefter I
apologize you're right he think he's
dumb yes I'm really dumb he's amazing
man his connections are endless in the
NFL so yes I mean he might do some just
throw it out there because it's he's
trying to do a favor for a team every
now and but he knows everything that's
going are you gonna say though now I was
gonna say so I mean we talked about my
haircuts a lot but can we talk about you
going on a couple's men mani-pedi
yesterday I mean you want to talk about
that I mean gee we're nails look nice
and shiny today thanks bro oh my gosh if
I did this you pay $400 for a haircut
yes I did this because I didn't
collected my girlfriend for a long time
because of the draft it's unbelievable
how a $40 combination of hands and feet
make you feel like a different person
yeah I got me I'm wiggling I got that
and then I did check out the Instagram
with her what was that Backstreet Boys
dancing mr. social media man I'm all
over it
does it work like your wife sees it and
goes Chris you need to see this yeah
that was good I like that
okay anyway Cleveland Browns yes I think
when I look at the Browns draft it's
gonna be very interesting to compare it
to the Giants draft because the Giants
picked right after the Browns in a lot
of cases and took guys that I kind of
thought the Browns should take yeah you
know say Kwan maybe not and then later
on the guard the Browns took instead of
will her man yeah and then later they
took a running back and Nick Chubb but
overall John Doerr sees draft yes what
do you think of it now as a few days
later I just
Denzel Ward at four Greg Williams said
that they needed a press corner to
create time for Garrett right when asked
about chub Williams said Aguas a rising
star in this lead a really good play
he's got a chance to beach up I don't
know that was and I was like damn so you
you have a vet that's been there that
you think has a chance to be a guy that
hasn't even played a snap in the NFL
yeah no he's not an explosive of a man
as Bradley Chubb is I mean he's a big
strong man he's certainly a good
football player manuel agua but no he's
not the pass rusher the trouble is I
mean the Browns draft it's weird
I don't want to sit here and hate on
them they dress needs they did things
they did got a lot of good players it
all comes down to Baker well it comes in
to Baker and a really good Ward well I
mean you know my thoughts on the corners
dens award was not 15 picks better than
JR Alexander or 24 picks better than
Mike Hughes that the Minnesota Vikings
picked so to me again you know I know
there was other 26 26 picks yeah so yes
I would have you know I liked those
corners more than Denzel words I think
the only way that I'm gonna be able to
keep track of it is if I do left go
picks what I would have done versus the
Browns and then look three years from
now and go was I correct yeah sure so
they went Baker at one I would have gone
sake 101 and then everyone's like well
you don't know Baker would have been
there at four okay well the Giants of
sake one wasn't there they're either
gonna go a SAM darn old or they're gonna
go a pass rusher at three the Jets
betting on Quentin Nelson really just
flat-out two and then the Jets you said
their board was what it was gonna be
Donald or Rosen it was one or two so one
of them was gonna be there so I do think
Baker would have been there at four he
would have been there at four so then my
draft would have been say Quon Baker and
if not I would have gone say Guan or
Rosen or say Kwan and Sam whatever and
in the second pick they went the Corbett
kid I would have gone will Hernandez I
went to the Giants or the guard that was
right after him the Braden Smith kid
that the Indianapolis Colts and Chris
Ballard took and he was better too and
then your corner from Auburn Carlton
Davis yes he went in the second round so
instead of taking that corner
for I would say the second round so I
could have gone running back quarterback
guard cornerback and - Baker say Quan
we'll Hernandez and Carlton Davis and
I'll compare that to them in three years
and we'll see if Dorsey's right yeah but
I don't want to hate on Baker I feel
like today I was reading Peter Kings
article and all these articles and
they're all glowing about Baker right
and I get it I think he's really good I
just think you could have gotten him at
four and the true thing is is we'll
never know but I'm fairly confident I'm
pretty confident from from my sources
yes that they could have got him yeah I
really am
no I'll throw in like another thing just
that's kind of cool about the Cleveland
Browns and what they did is beginning
the Antonio Callaway kid who's had some
off-the-field issues the Florida
receiver he's got superstar potential he
definitely does yes he is explosive
great hips good route and runner I mean
he can do something but Baker Mayfield
you have caught what are you so I think
your take is interesting on that yeah go
ahead you want to hear my take take me
to training camp yes well I think your
may feel goes or one of these camps next
week they're gonna have their first mini
camp or OTA right and this is the this
is the two situations this one
especially I look at and go okay here's
the first pick of the draft everybody's
gonna be so excited to them they're
gonna make them the number three
quarterback to start out and what
they're gonna realize they're gonna see
him next to their starting quarterback
Tyrod Taylor they go damn okay they're
the same height okay yep same height
oh and tie rods arms just as strong
maybe oh it's probably a little stronger
than Baker Mayfield Oh tie rods faster
than Baker Dan this is our first pick
he's he's he's not as good at anything
is the guy that's our starter right now
I mean that's what I would be scared of
in Cleveland it's did something to worry
about seriously and you've talked before
about needing the team to be impressed
by a big-time first round rookie yeah
you see them for the first time yes
because it's just gonna you know again
if like AJ McCarron and Josh Allen
they're gonna go I see why he was that's
why I would if you made me go who's the
rookie quarterback that gets on the
field first I'm gonna go with Josh Allen
first of all Josh Allen ran a pro-style
offense Josh Allen has shown that he can
correct some of the mechanical issues
like you saw in the the Senior Bowl the
pro day the combine all those things but
also
but exactly at the end of the day
they're gonna stand next to each other
and everyone's gonna go man Josh Allen's
got about 20 pounds of muscle on AJ
McCarron and whoa he's a whole lot
faster and holy crap is Armstrong holy
oh did you see that yeah I mean that's
what's gonna happen and that's gonna be
automatically it's gonna be okay we get
something to work here right and then
the whole team gets the whole team
because I said just like we were with
Philadelphia and Carson once a few years
ago Fletcher Cox told him told my dad at
a practice no no I get up to watch
Carson because he can do some good [ __ ]
it's funny because Carson was on the
same field with Bradford right and you
think that could actually be an issue
for Rosen now in Arizona I do a little
bit yes just because again it's gonna be
the same type of thing
Rosen's gonna get out there and Rosen
you know I like Rosen a lot but Sam
Bradford's got talent and they have a
similar body bill the same with Glennon
out there it's the same kind of guy and
I just think they're all gonna go damn
this is our first round pick and Sam
Bradford looks just like them and
they're similar type athlete and man
Bradford throws it maybe every bit as
good if not maybe even a little bit
better and I just think that could cause
little issues at times I mean there's no
doubt that Rosen will be the guy I know
that at some point but but those are
just things that players are gonna look
at and go well what's so damn special
about him yeah I think it's be
interesting with Baker I think that
Johnny Manziel stuff has gone a little
bit too far he's not Johnny Manziel and
Denzel Ward is not Justin Gill no Justin
Gilbert had a number of off the field
this both of those guys did everybody in
the NFL knew it too and Cleveland just
said the hell with it we'll take him
Baker's gonna wear six with the brown
school
Josh Rosen's gonna wear three with the
Cardinals right Josh Allen's wearing 17
with the bills okay
darn old hasn't announces nice Toby
doesn't wear 14 and Lamar Jackson's
wearing eight right yeah what do you
mean not 14 for Darnell 14 ugly in
general okay he didn't look good at USC
and I like Sam he's the man and 14 like
of Richard Todd Lord that for the New
York Jets back in the 80s like come on
we gotta work at a better now I think
you were saying about these these rookie
quarterbacks walking into new situations
and I think darn 'old is the perfect one
yeah McGowan McGowan has a daughter yeah
that is about
the same age as darn 'old so he doesn't
have any weird ideas teddy is going to
fight but I think that darn 'old is more
talented than teddy yes but it gives you
good competition the other ones
Tyrod is going to try and beat Baker
Mayfield no doubt about it
AJ McCarron is going to try and beat
Josh I'll write that one it seems more
like the teddy bridgewater one but the
Baker Mayfield or Sam Bradford is
definitely gonna try and beat out yeah
Josh Rosen right I think Allan and
Arnold are the best spots like you said
you're right Arnold isn't a journalist
the best one great space he is because
there's no denying that is the future
there's no rush to get there nope and if
he's ready you go okay he's ready and we
will have Josh McCown behind him to be a
support system and somebody that can
help him study and be that cuz he's
willing to take it on an acre might be
I'm gonna say this to you talked about
tie rods bigger tie rods faster tie rods
stronger tie rod is cooler like I'm just
gonna say this physical did one of the
cool things about Baker is that he
relates to everybody yeah I've seen Tyra
dress I've seen how teammates like get
up for Tyra
yeah every team that Tyrod has played
for he's the team favorite even when
he's the backup even when he was behind
Joe Flacco better than yours I'm calling
is if Baker is gonna be the cool guy too
yeah Tyrod has you beaten that yeah I
know I just I think it's interesting I
think that I think that Baker is a good
player that will have success yeah he's
not Johnny Manziel but he's also not
Russell Wilson right I think he's
somewhere in between yeah and so is
Tyrod yeah that's why it's gonna be
interest yes it is I just don't like
when the team comes out and says we took
Denzel Ward because of need because when
you're a top five pick you're taking in
the words of Dave Gettleman
you're trying to get a future
hall-of-famer you're not trying to take
Forney mmm-hmm cuz we just heard Bill
Belichick talk about need yes and we
agreed with him yeah so I'm not going
back on it now no I mean and again I
mean they obviously had a very high you
know great on Denzel Wars which a lot of
teams did I mean I know it there was a
ton of teams that did so I don't think
it's I don't think they did anything
totally crazy or different than what a
lot of teams would have done maybe with
the number four pick if they had a
corner spot but yeah again I just think
I'm not sure of the value
was quite right there I think it could
have played out different ways like
again I'm not mad at them I guess I'm
just not impressed here's what I think
it is I was trying to talk to Matt in
the in the lobby when you're trying to
talk about big boards during the draft
yeah it's comparing religions hey I
believe in this and I believe in that
and you say well I don't I believe in
this and I believe in that and the true
thing is is your religion your board is
different than mine
yeah and I have to see your board and
see why you see it that way and
appreciate you but I need to understand
that until we see these guys in the
field we're just gonna think completely
different of these guys yeah
it's gonna take until the preseason yeah
it really is yeah well because all those
reports that's what we make fun of whoa
big offseason whoa like Baker Mayfield
already slinging into practice walking
off C's until I see game speed yes it
does not matter doesn't matter Josh
Rosen in Arizona he came out and said I
was a little emotional last night about
saying nine mistakes in front of me
someone said but he was on your show and
said if I go in the second round it just
means I don't get a personal chef I
think when you're in the green room for
an hour and a half yeah and the cameras
on you and you're watching Baker may
feel to hug all of his family and
friends and go out there and be
celebrated and then Josh Allen gets
drafted ahead of you and do the same
thing I think you get a little hot at it
he said I was a little emotional he said
he didn't mean to include the include
the six nine quarterbacks right oh like
say Kron was a mistake it too no yeah
neither was Bradley trouble right right
but do you think how soon do you think
Rosen's playing in Arizona is that
offensive line yeah I mean Rosen's the
guy that we know if he's ready throw him
out there don't waste your time no knees
yeah he's ready I mean just the if if
you feel like after a few weeks of OTAs
and you get in the training camp and go
okay he's got the offense down and he
seems physically comfortable well what's
the point what are we waiting for
yeah that's right that's all right I
mean so and then what are we gonna do
what put Sam Bradford out there for four
weeks till his knee gives out again and
then we're gonna throw Josh Rosen enix
Ari we haven't given you any reps in
five weeks but now we'd like you to win
games for us yeah so that to me if any
of them are ready get them out there
come on that day's over of all we go sit
behind and groom certainly like listen
if that
itself out there is a perfect situation
great but there's nothing better than
being on the field and dealing with live
bullets there's nothing that can beat
that
Cardinals didn't want Josh Rosen no they
did not they tried to trade to Josh down
on everything I know is that the number
five picked with the Broncos the trade
was in place and it was with Arizona and
it was at Arizona if that would have
been the surprise was on the board in no
way wasn't willing to do that that was
the things I was told yeah the IRA zone
of Cardinals were heartbroken they did
not get Josh Allen yeah it's because the
Browns the Browns screwed the Cardinals
right by the Browns passing on Bradley
Chubb Elway when I was going to trade
but this is one of the few guys I didn't
think would be he exactly so but so then
Arizona takes their second favorite
quarterback man that's crazy
yeah it's crazy for that to kind of come
out cuz now Allen and and Rosen were
just gonna be comparing no doubt about
it yeah they are it's all right they got
a good quarterback they're gonna be fine
I mean he's certainly he's gonna he's
gonna be absolutely fine in Arizona it's
a good spot for him he's gonna good good
offensive coordinator Mike McCoy he's
got good two good quarterbacks that have
burden around the block they're a
building team they're not like anything
special we know that right now and there
was something else I was going to say
about Josh Rosen but I cannot forget
what it was going to be but oh dude yeah
I mean so what that he said the nine
guys everybody is so like oh now oh good
now he cares too much he cares too much
he didn't care about football enough
before the draft but damn it now he
cares too much come on find a middle
ground Josh you're not perfect yet we
can't it's all over the place again
here's another guy that we're just gonna
talk about every little thing he says
and talks about and does I don't give a
damn oh he wanted to be the number one
pick yes he did eat crap everybody else
out there okay my goal is to show Sims
and Lefko listeners how easy the mini
media is to manipulate whenever we can
the next player that we have in person
I'm going to get them to say that
they're going to win the Super Bowl or
that's their goal and the media is just
gonna run with it just like they did
meleave right but what are these guys
supposed to say our goal we want to lose
the divisional round to me that's a news
story if Josh Rosen said honestly I
thought I would've been drafted lower
that's a news story being upset with
that you people went ahead of you it's
not a new stone oh and he's got
quarterbacks that it's personal too he's
seen them in person one of them we
played against on a crosstown rival he
doesn't want to be behind him I mean
yeah you said it he's in the green room
with a camera on his face all time I
stayed in my house okay and when the
first round went by dim I was so pissed
I told my friends to get the eff out of
my house I said get the hell out of here
I'm done for the day it almost happened
a little more Jackson yes and you heard
the Ravens would have been comfortable
taking him at 16 yes they wanted to take
him at 16 but Tremaine Edmonds was still
on the board and the Colts moved up got
the call the coffin the bills so then
one of the Ravens do the Ravens from
what I know called the few teams behind
them that thought that they might be
interested in Lamar Jackson got answers
that they liked and felt like okay we we
feel okay we're gonna roll the dice and
if he can last at the end of the first
we'll make a play up for him once again
is Baltimore a good situation for the
margin I think it's perfect really I
really do yeah I mean first of all cuz
that's the concern with Lamar's we
didn't know where he was gonna go with
the system what kind of coaching staff
John Harbaugh morning morning wig with a
run game football guys that are not
afraid of personalities whether that's
being antisocial or social or a
loudmouth or you know whatever it is
they don't care I just a run game
coordinator Greg Roman right who was out
there in San Francisco with Kaepernick
so that hadn't did any work with Tyrod
Taylor - yes so he's gonna be perfect
for them and Baltimore's a good
personality spot for them exactly yes
exactly right there they're not worried
about getting a guy that might be a
little rough around the edges or if he's
a choirboy and he can play football he
knocks people heads off a brain come to
our team if you're tough and you about
football
Baltimore I'll take it right but do you
think that so what do they do with Joe
Flacco how do you think this navigates
it I mean this is the last year for Joe
Flacco it's got to be I mean you're kind
of cool with it at this I mean yeah
there's I can't defend Joe Flacco
anymore I spent years defending him and
I do think that people were too harsh on
him throughout his whole career I mean
he was an offense that never had huge
talent they weren't really about always
putting up offensive number
are worried about the quarterback thrown
for 4,000 yards it was kind of just like
no we run we play defense Joe we need
you to make some big throws and he did
that and never really got the full
credit but he doesn't now we're at the
point where he's not making the big
throws anymore or the big plays and then
he brings nothing else to the table to I
mean he's not Johnny personality he's
not Johnny leadership he has the same
reaction whether he throws a 50-yard
touchdown or a 50-yard pick six it's the
same Joe Flacco it's a little Jay Cutler
ish to where you go damn come on get
pissed off do something yell at your
team whatever but don't just seem
content to collect the check and I think
that's what Baltimore probably is a
problem with more than anything they
have to again they are about people who
love football this is the FIFA realities
this is the team that had Ray Lewis this
is John Hawkes I left or else all right
Doron Harbaugh is ready to fight head
coaches at the midfield before a game I
mean they they want guys that have like
a burn in them and that's where I think
he they don't think he's bringing
anything extra to the field you said you
said this in podcast leading up yeah get
Lamar on the field receiver it's gonna
cause a holster right but it's just to
be in there be in the huddle listening
yeah now Joe does that use of the speed
of the game oh this makes me hot when
these two it's all gonna help him play
quarterback in the long run so the sixth
quarterback taken also went to the AFC
North dealers Mason Rudolph is this the
replacement for Ben or is this a
replacement for Landry Jones I don't
think it's the replacement for Ben I
think they took a guy that they saw ok
he's big he moves around the pocket they
throw some good deep balls let's see if
we can maybe right that's how he's a
maybe pick and I think that's all there
is to it I mean how you know we've we've
done this and Ben fell in this trap
before right like with Garrett Grayson
when they drafted him down in New
Orleans oh is this the Drew Brees
success plan no it's not it's very rare
that the mid round guy actually ends up
being that guy right exactly right so I
don't see it I do let listen I want to
give my Steelers the Steelers Mike
Tomlin has been getting a lot of crap
because of their first-round pick
Terrell Edmonds yeah let me just set the
record straight forget what all the
draft
experts say out there okay this kid is a
baller he was the third best safety in
the draft for me I mean he was it was
Minka Fitzpatrick Derwin James and then
Terrell Edmonds I mean his film was
phenomenal
if
read my notes you'd go okay I mean when
you're he's 6-1 200-pound 220 pounds 72
17 right ran for four has phenomenal
hips
I mean his coverage was I mean I was
jaw-dropping how good he wasn't coverage
and then his ability to come up and
tackle yeah I mean he's a freak athlete
it was a good pick by them hmm makes him
what Sean Davis man him and I mean I how
happy is their mom today I mean you talk
about like a mom I should have made
heard the winner on the videos a good
one damn I miss that alright so say Quan
did go to and I didn't realize how much
you and Dave gentlemen had in common I
love this quote but I thought not only
did he say he likes big butts but he
also I apologize like I'm like all the
time but gentlemen also starts off
almost every point with let me tell you
something just like what my dad does
gentleman's a character I he's hilarious
this is the thickest Bach Boston accent
I've ever heard hey we like some hog
Molly's over here that's the other thing
he's been saying up here in the news hog
Molly's which is like code word for big
asses and big people so I I look and you
your power rankings came out two teams
had huge jumps the Packers went from 22
to 11 and I'm sure it's because Aaron
Rodgers his health I wrote in my thing
he's worth at least seven spots yes so I
knew that but the team that jumped up 17
spots you had the Giants move from 31 to
14 I know
and they leapfrog half the NFL right
what's good what do you think well I
don't think much it is say Quan and will
Hernandez and Lorenzo Carter it's all of
the free agents getting rid of jpp in
the DRC's who were cancers in their
locker room it was it's the whole
changing in the culture in the
dysfunctional way of been McAdoo's world
to get a Shermer in there whose
no-nonsense a Gettleman
no nonsense I just think all of those
things and of course you know Shurmur is
an improvement and just the offensive
creative system who played center for
them at the end of the last year
Oh at the end gosh you're gonna I don't
even remember because Nate's older at
left tackle with will Hernan Daz at left
guard and the guy that filled in pretty
admirably at center all of a sudden the
Giants have a strength on their line
it's the left side of that line yes and
it could be pretty good next year for
somebody like say Kwan
I just think schirmer's in a good
situation with a lot of weapons right
now I mean a lot of weapons I mean is
there a more explosive offensive
Steelers maybe the Steelers maybe you're
right I mean there have experienced
doing it because the thing that make
more explosive though I don't really
think they are said this during the
wrath yes what's the excuse for Eli
going to be now yes right you can't have
one because they've made excuses up from
your up here in New York and again I'm
gonna sound like I'm an Eli Manning
hater cuz my dad still since I don't
really give a crap
Eli's greatest quarterback of Giants
history I don't care I'm just telling
you keeping it real yeah it hasn't been
good play from Eli Manning and the
excuse up here in the New York media as
well if you put a good offensive line
with him and give him a good running
back and give him good receivers he
could still be good well no crap so can
anybody so we got that you're right sir
we want the running back yes he's got
the receivers yeah he's got the tight
end
he's got the left tackle right he's got
it he's got it there let's see they're
stacked I mean what do you do
you gotta go damn say Kwan out of the
backfield we got to worry about him
underneath Oh Evan Engram behind the
linebackers air oh crap holy cow he's
amazing he's like Jordan Reed oh gosh my
gosh
and Odell Beckham jr. is running across
the field at a 60 yard post I mean it's
phenomenal
and then Sterling Shepherd second-round
pick yeah I mean it's it's they're
stacked right now that's why I mean just
between the those changes okay getting
some of those characters out of the
locker room it all comes down to Eli
comes down to Eli the defense new scheme
that I believe in even more edge come on
it's it's hard to come up with a team
that has more stars on their roster than
the New York Giants right I mean Collins
jinora is Jenkins and you know you still
got Olivier Vernon and you got
knacks Harrison and you start to go
through the names and it's like now like
ogle trailing Ogletree exactly right you
start to go through and you go damn
there's a lot of names on the New York
Giants
my other favorite soundbite this one is
ridiculous Jim Irsay his call to quit
Nelson I haven't heard this yet how can
you talk everyone is focusing on the end
of the call and I'll play it for you
when he says we need to protect Andrew
but no one is talking about the
beginning of the call right
we just are say in general I can't
imagine Jim Irsay is my boss
quittin Nelson is that a is that a lake
house with this family you're going to
hear the new head coach Frank Reich pass
it off Wally passes off you're gonna
hear quitting Nelson be like let's go
and then Irsay comes on and it's just
Jim mercy
it sounded it sounded like Eminem's
character Ken Kenneth when he first
started rap he's like Ken keenya from
Connecticut like water you'd like I
can't believe that's the owner of the
team and then he goes on this is the
mind of Jim Irsay listen to the ego
about the guys he's watched in his life
[Music]
[Music]
he said sound so creepy
I've seen muñoz and I've seen them toss
around and he goes on for so long in the
kids not Alissa anymore but then he ends
it with this is the quote that
everyone's talking about but for me I
just think I need the beginning of that
call like I think that's the the Earth's
say that I know
which is you know he's you know he's got
like a special box hey what's up man you
want to come up to my luxury box and
smoke some cigarettes in there you know
he has that in there what do you mean in
his luxury box he has a special glass
tin box within a box so he can rip
through cigarettes inside it has its own
little system I've seen it it's like it
quit Nelson man I told he told me he's
gonna throw some bodies these cigarettes
give me the good [ __ ] and you wonder
like like they needed Chris Ballard they
really needed Chris Ballard he went out
there and drafted your guide too right
he did I I'm uh
the Colts killed it they were one of the
teams certainly you'd look at and go
they had a phenomenal dress so Irsay
came out and said they got trade calls
for luck and he said they said trust me
I'll read into my in my voice trust me
man there are people who would give an
unprecedent amount of draft picks for
him all with a number one behind them
and we wouldn't even consider it man
you're on your own point with this guy
yeah we're confident about that let's
just say yeah but do you think people
were really calling trying no I just
have a hard time thinking that like NFL
teams were like hey you know that
quarterback you're paying 26 million a
year for it his shoulder it hasn't been
a throw in a year and a half
can we have them I just I'm not sure if
I'm buying it I think that there are
little story lines that GM's and stuff
stay right after the draft if there's no
reporter in the in the draft room to
sell everything oh you know what we
actually he was number one on our board
when I came on and you're like they got
the top player on their board or I know
you're gonna defend this but Rashad
Penny John Schneider came out and said a
true rarity is that we had a team call
after we selected him and tried to
acquire him I've never experienced that
I feel very blessed
that was a good selling point Emsworth
so interested in the reach for a running
back at the end of round one yeah they
wanted to trade so it feels like
validation right why does everybody so
mad with that one but not mad at like
Sony Michelle or because I think that in
our culture a mock draft culture yeah
we're if we see someone they're like
Maurice Hirst right people were going
how is he still on the board people that
have not watched any film or anything
but because they saw mocks yes your mind
gets comfortable and I think Rashad
penny was in none of the mocks none of
them are you came out and said he's my
second favorite running he was right
there I gave Tony Michelle the title the
second favor and again I'm so
disappointed we didn't do more draft
videos this year because you didn't get
to deep dive in my notes but like yes I
wrote I watched I watched Berkeley I
watched ice I watched Michelle I watch
Rashad Penny all consecutively and when
I got done with Rashad Penny I went oh I
brought in the bottom of my notes man it
is really close between him and Sony
Michelle for the second best back in
this draft I said I'm and I broke my
last line was I'm gonna go with Michelle
just because he played in the SEC and
but penny is talented he was a
first-round caliber running back and you
know again you know the value of that
I'm kind of sick of hearing everybody
talk about these running backs and OH
sequel Berkeley you could you could make
him a number two running back circle
from everywhere okay but you know the
two best running backs is some of the
best running backs in football we're
also top 10 picks I mean Ezekiel it's he
would be like the number one back in
football for me when he can get him he's
he was a top-10 pick okay Todd Gurley
was a top-10 pick so if science could
have time I know I understand right I
understand that levy on bells went in
the second round and some of those
things like that and there's been other
guys too but say Quan was different from
all of them say Quan is the best running
back to come out since Adrian Peterson
he is that special he's worth the second
pick the running other running back
thing listen if you're talented you're
talented who cares the rookie wage skill
does not exist anymore so you're not
paying like like when I was in the Bucks
in 2005 we kind of like well I'm you're
70 million for a running back who only
lasted four years what's wild is there's
no rookie wage scale yet say Quan I
believe is the second highest paid
running back in the NFL and there's no
rookie wage scale right there is no
rookie waves go
it's not the inflated yeah Sam Bradford
like a hundred million dollars and never
brought a game right but that's how low
running backs get paid yes but say Quan
looks to be someone that's deserving
right it's so so I think the Rashad
Penney thing is also this yeah we talked
about a lot with bias and I think if you
remember daryl morey you cannot compare
a guy that looks like another guy in the
NBA
you also can't compare him to somebody
that played on his team and I think that
was a factor Johnnie Mae Baker Mayfield
is being negatively impacted because he
looks like Johnny Manziel yes Derwin
James was probably inflated by some
people because oh he looks like Jalen
Ramsay right no he's just wearing a
Florida State Jersey and it's hard to
get over that genell prom free played
for San Diego State last year right the
guy that led the nation in rushing same
team as Rashad Penney and he was a bust
they are completely different people
Danelle pumphrey weighs like 160 Rashad
penny weighs 220 but because they both
played at that school it's impossible
for someone to succeed when someone just
failed yeah we couldn't get over the
fact we can we could yeah that Patrick
mahomes was a good prospect and played
it too you know you're right about that
but for a lot of people because he
played at Texas Tech right even though
they've had two to three coaching
changes and it's not you know Kliff
Kingsbury right it could actually be
successful yeah and that's I think it's
hard for people I did this they get they
get enamored with the emblems on the
helmet some of the storylines you write
like you know this is another one that
drives me crazy I hear sometimes the
draft guys like always only a one year
starter but then the number four pick in
the draft I was ok he's a number 1 he's
in one year started that wasn't a
problem for him but the other guys I'm
downgrading them a few points because
they were a 1 year starter but the guys
I liked they're allowed to be one-year
starters that's like that's the double
talk is what drives me crazy in the
draft season because I sometimes want to
go like do you hear the words that are
coming out of your mouth have you
listened a read read back what some of
these guys say I want to go wait
sometimes they talk about a player
glowingly and they go he's a fifth or a
sixth round pick and I wanna go you just
talked about him like he was a second
rounder you did that with Baker Mayfield
right I do went back and read your words
and went I think I actually have them at
fifth I think I haven't behind darn the
night before the draft I went through
because I was going you know we read
back to my notes to see if there's any
points things and I went back through
the quarterbacks and I said damn you
know my report does not read that Baker
Mayfield is a third best quarterback in
the describe I'm actually gonna say this
right now this is a public service
announcement
if athletes keep things that analysts
say as motivation that's fine if you
think we're trying to impact your draft
stock or if you think that we don't like
you as a person you're crazy if anything
you should respect us more that we're
willing to talk honestly about you and
if Baker ends up being Russell Wilson
you could play this clip and/or throw it
right back tell you the only way we
could do our job yeah is to just be
honest and it's all we can do we work
hard we be honest that's all there is to
it I'm gonna mess up I know that like
you said him during the draft I said
Greg Robinson second pick of the st.
Louis Rams gonna be a Hall of Fame left
tackle man his ass ain't blocked anybody
since he got in the league yeah so I
mean you're gonna be wrong Bill
Belichick is wrong about Drop picks all
the time if he can be wrong then I can
be too I think that my favorite part of
the draft obviously is an Eagles home or
if I can go on about this first of all
Jason Witten suddenly retires before the
second day of the draft day two we're
doing day one they come up to pick they
end up picking Layton van Dhiresh the
Dallas Cowboy fan contingent walked out
which is unbelievable even though but
when it came up I said are they gonna
take the tight end from South Carolina
because you know Jason Witten is getting
old and we're like now they don't really
need them then he retires and they're
like blindsided right now Jason went
apparently reportedly is being offered
for a four and a half million a year to
do Monday Night Football if he gets all
of his roster bonuses he might not even
touch two million for the cows I see one
point oh five million up to seven
hundred fifty thousand in per game
roster bonuses but I saw they readjusted
some bonuses and if the number I saw it
might be four point seven so you're
getting your year plus the future and we
saw this with Romo we saw this with
Keyshawn Johnson you might have to end
your career short to get up
rod casting job like that but it does
seem very unwitnessed it does I mean I
know you and I are the same way I mean
again we're just gonna keep it real here
I mean jason witten has been Johnny
model good citizen he has a Geico
commercial it's just him blocking and
jumping over pads right because he
doesn't say anything because he's that
good of a team I mean he truly is
anything you can't
he's a choirboy he's a Boy Scout you
can't find anything wrong with him but
this was wrong I mean to me you've had
the whole offseason and then you're
gonna blindside the football team on the
what if he just got the offer cuz Greg
Olson turned it down but but okay but so
he obviously knew this was they at least
were in some some conversation he's at
least been telling his agent to at least
talk and so he's at least had it had
others radar but it tells you that he
hasn't even discussed it with the
Cowboys because the Cowboys came out and
said it's news to me
and then they came and then they had to
have him in the facility on Friday
before the draft to have another talk
about convinced so that tells you that
it's real I mean just from connecting
the dots right there and that also tells
you that yeah he had not informed the
team of that so yeah I mean that just
bothered me from that aspect where again
because he's squeaky clean and all that
everyone everyone's just you know it's
okay it's okay
he's been so good and he's such a good
guy his whole career know that was a
messed up move it's dirty way to do your
team and the cowboys and let me also say
this
what is this booth more likely to do Joe
tessitura and Jason Witten more likely
to broadcast a Dallas Cowboys preseason
game or be the faces of Monday Night
Football that's just me being Adam left
Co watching media I cannot believe
that's gonna be the booth nurses Jon
Gruden and Sean McDonough to Joe
tessitura and Jason Witten Jason
wouldn't you think he's gonna have like
some real groundbreaking analysis I
think it's gonna be like oh it was a
good throw there Joe right you're not
gonna talk [ __ ] hey well no I just I
don't know how you're right I don't even
know enough about his personality like I
know what Greg Olson could be and I
think Greg Olson right also would be the
one would be funny and quit me oh
diaochan be like Joe that's a weird tire
like Johnny Witten just like it's about
blocking and execution exactly it does
seem that way I don't know him on up but
you're right know these guys that are
retiring and it's like dude if you want
to go to
all sucks get terrell suggs of the booth
that would be entertaining you know and
then you know we trot Rex Ryan out there
I don't know like it's it's bad I'm just
gonna say though that as an Eagles fan
for Drew Pearson to be in Philly last
year and to hear the boos and go five
times Superbowl champion and then the
Dallas Cowboys are sitting there
blindsided that Jason Witten has retired
sitting there going what are we gonna do
and they're sitting there and here comes
the number two tight end in the class
he's super talented his name is Dallas
Goddard named after the Dallas Cowboys
they're gonna be getting him in two
picks and they're going come to Papa
what a seamless transition Jason take
Monday Night Football
we got an open ceremony we can roll out
the red carpet and the Eagles trade up
and David Akers goes out there and says
hey cowboys fans the last time you won a
Super Bowl
these kids were important yet and by the
way we're taking the tight end named
Dallas I mean talk about owning it yeah
he loved it especially because there
were rumors talk like this he was like
where the world champion Philadelphia
Eagles he was a kicker he was kicked
from Texas that's when I got a kick out
it was amazing it wasn't that was that
was and what's funny is I think it was
very fortuitous apparently there was a
rumor that t/o was going to be the one
that did the Eagles pick at 32 to merge
the Eagles and the Cowboys together and
not only did the Eagles not have to deal
with that they traded it so that Lamar
Jackson could be a first-round pick
because I wanted the revenge of Drew
Pearson to be the david akers
yes if tio would have come out it would
have kind of touched that away right and
tio would have come out probably like a
split jersey and be like hey I play it
for both teams is tio gonna go in the
Hall of Fame as an eagle no are you sure
I heard you want to go in as a 49er now
I don't know that would be cool take two
man Brian donkey cool um what do you
think of the draft what do you mean I
mean did we keep doing this city tour
did we just put it back in New York
what's your take because it sounds like
you have an opinion oh I just like New
York better I thought the Philadelphia
woman was Philadelphia was cool it was
outside it was better than this one for
sure well it's because Dallas everything
about Dallas I can see the price tag
sticking out and there's nothing there
it's the stadium in the middle of
nowhere like where yours was at least
it's downtown guys can walk you to the
bar or whatever it may be there's an
experience yes I don't get it I don't
get it
Dallas is looking at as a monetary gain
yeah you know they have like all the
fans sitting there assigned segments
sections and all that stuff you're right
with New York you had the line out front
of Radio City of New York City it makes
it a bigger deal I just feel like it's a
little bit bigger a spectacle and I'm
old-school and I understand that so
we're gonna keep moving it because it's
becoming a thing I don't like how you
know we talked about they're gonna do
all those surprise picks there's gonna
be a parrot there's gonna be someone in
space I don't need a random kid in every
city announcing everything no that's why
our draft coverage really that's where
my all my friends just go they you guys
kill it because we're ahead of everybody
else that's on TV our picture always
ahead yeah we talked about the pigs and
I'm gonna say this if they want to keep
moving it I'm kind of down to throw our
own draft event in New York from now on
okay so thank you party somewhere yeah
you want to keep moving it right maybe
we take this on the road and maybe we
get a venue and maybe people watch the
draft with us in New York cuz I know we
got fans I think that would be cool and
then we have people like who can
literally ask us questions live there
instead of us just sitting here at the
desk trying to fix I'm saying yeah I
think it could be cool if they want to
run away from New York right we can own
it we can own it I'm down let's do it
all right
pound it pound it found me this late in
van der ash let's just talk about him
really quick is that cowboy just love
white line back a little bit I mean I do
think it was uh for me the thing I
looked at with that pic he's big he's
got incredible physical ability that is
without question I get that I did not
think he was the most physical player I
saw at the middle linebacker position I
actually questioned whether he was a
true NFL middle linebacker I thought
really more he's like a three-four
outside linebacker more
like a TJ watt if anything but they
don't buy the 3/4 there so they're gonna
use them as in the box type of guy yeah
I just think it's risky when you've
drafted Jaylon Smith who has nerve
damage
you have Shawn Lee Gregory right right
exactly Randy Gregory who the drug
program got back to them and that was
all those warnings were there Sean
leaves a concussion away from being done
forever forever
you lost Anthony Hitchens and you go
with a guy that some teams wiped off
their board because of medical issues
and Rashad Evans was the andra Sean
Evans was there that that to me
I just I devid be one rabbit again I
just go let me just go with the safe one
here in Rashad Evans they draft that kid
gallop
yeah wide receiver and they trade for
Tavon Austin right you raised her
eyebrows is Tavon Austin gonna be more
in Dallas than he was with the Rams I
think so I mean I think they're there
yes I don't think they can they also
traded Ryan Switzer to the Raiders right
that I think hey Vaughn tavon I think
just in Dallas like they're gonna use
them just because their lack of other
pie makers so I don't think they're
overly complicated and what they do
offensively there but I think he's going
to be mr. slot receivers speed sweeps
third down back out of the backfield
stop trying to make him Darren Sproles
instead of trying to make him Julian
Edelman was what I feel like everybody's
trying to do make him Darren Sproles
that's what he is
let him be back there he's quick as hell
nobody can ever get a clean shot on him
so don't worry about whether he gets
beat up or whatever else and and then
integrate him into the game that way but
yeah they're a team that I expected to
take a receiver they didn't really do
that that was it well they took two
receivers I mean I know the receiver
early on yeah other trades I want to go
on these trades martavis Bryant that's
that's right pause I was gonna go to
that but yes let's talk about yeah I
mean that was I think the best move of
the whole draft for the race funny
because it was met with such negativity
and it's funny because they're going you
gave up a third-round pick four martavis
Bryant and I'm going
Martinez probably only cost you a
third-round pick yeah like not enough
people like the Patriots got Trent Brown
for what a third-round pick also right
and I'm going do you really think you
were gonna get a 6-8 340 tackle with pro
experience for a third in the third
round you
right like martavis Bryant has already
proved that he is one of the elite
athletes in the NFL right he had some
drug issues yeah he battled back he had
some fighting with the Steelers but
let's be real levian is still fighting
with the Steelers and Big Ben got in a
fight with the offensive coordinator to
the point where he had to get fired
right so it doesn't really sound like
the Steelers are like a kumbaya yeah and
martavis was the one riling up right and
to be honest you can't you see Jon
Gruden going martavis that fire man I
need that fire here man come on like
he's a him and Amari Cooper like you got
something special now do I think it's a
good value I think people are still bad
mouth and martavis and I to me there's a
lot of trash talkers in Pittsburgh and a
lot of like crap well I mean yeah I mean
I think you're right to a degree I mean
think about it you made the good point
actually
look at the I mean Antonio Brown had an
issue with the team a little bit James
Harrison's had a team so there's been a
little bit of that to go on up there I'm
not mad at like martavis Bryant yeah he
messed up he failed drug test he missed
you you're a football that's his fault
we get that it's not like a bad guy I
don't think anybody's going to like
martavis Bryant he's a cancer in the
locker room and you know he's out on the
streets being a bad guy when he leaves
the football facility no it's another
quote that became a thing like he's
upset he's not playing yeah that's like
wow you think he's a bad guy like what
do you want to say I mean I'm
appreciating my limited role look ejuice
my bench is phenomenal over here I just
I know yeah he has a chance to be a star
in Oakland and he's just he's another
guy just that's the rage like a ring we
should make him and Gruden wear patches
on their eyes together yeah no you have
to make martavis bryant sit on Gruden to
shoulder he's the new para the new para
Trent Brown to the Patriots yeah
the 49ers did this after drafting Mike
McGlinchey will be the right tackle
likely the future left tackle of the
49ers it's funny how his stock grew in
like a day yeah but the Patriots getting
Trent Brown yeah is he a true patriots
guy he's enormous
he's enormous and that's what they like
yes he is a true patriots guy I mean he
is the Patriots believe in size on the
offensive line and especially in length
and that size - that's why they've had
the Nate's soldiers and the you know the
Sebastian volmers and of course even now
I mean Marcus cannon Lowe Adrian waddles
six eight they like those kind of guys
on the
Trent Brown is their type of right
tackle certainly it's gonna be for him
just learning a whole new system gonna
be a lot more rules in his offense all
that kind of stuff but yeah he's got I
mean Trump rounds a good right tackle in
the NFL he really is and he can
definitely help them out and you were
kind of thinking now with that offensive
line they draft Isaiah win yeah they're
gonna go Isaiah went at left guard Jeff
Mason a right guard Trent Brown at right
tackle right David Andrews at Center yep
and then the left tackle good may be
Marcus cap Marcus cannon or the kid they
got what is the kid they drafted last
year and Garcia Antonio Antonio Garcia
had they think a blood clot issue I
might be wrong there but it was
something like that where he didn't get
to play last year but he is he was a guy
that I know that they were super excited
about I think they want him to be the
future left tackle I think one other
trend that I'm seeing what the Patriots
is it's a little bit like Bella checks
coaching disciples haven't gone a lot of
places and had success but now we're
starting to see the GM disciples
starting to figure it out in Tennessee
in Detroit Bob Quinn and and John
Robinson yeah but I thought it was very
interesting the way both of those teams
drafted guys that I think Bella check
would have wanted yeah at 20 the Detroit
Lions took Frank rag Nell and the Titans
treated ahead of the Patriots to take
Rashad Evans a team that the Patriots
probably needed right and I was curious
and then later on the second round the
Titans treated a head of the Patriots
again to get trial and right right and
it's like they know those are true
Belichick disciples those guys they are
because they've been in the room that
you've talked about with the secret big
board and they know what Belichick wants
coaches they got a replicate the
coaching style that's hard coaches don't
get the inside look see the GM the
disciple thing can be good because they
actually get to see this is how the
front office works
I know all about the front office so I
can go be a GM somewhere else I might
not know every little trick of the trade
and Bill Belichick's mind about why he
made this trade but I know the scouting
system and knowing yes I know the type
of player bill values I know that that's
it yeah there's value exactly right I'm
seeing these teams now use it to their
advantage that I've never seen anyone
take advantage of
they're phenomenal listen Bob and you
trust those I really do they jump all
guys that I have so much respect for the
man I hated them to death at times and I
was working for them because they were I
mean it just was constant I mean it you
know it was like it was literally like
that movie where you had a pile of work
on your side you got down with it you're
getting to the end of it and there's
another one to pile right on you like
you mother yeah
but yes they are they have a great feel
for the game understand how to build a
team where the coaches who we go why
don't there are more good disciple
coaches they only get to see one side of
the ball few conversations okay I get to
implement the office but why did Bill
make these roster moves and all this
stuff they're kind of in the dark about
those decisions I think that's why
sometimes it doesn't translate it always
the right away the other thing the other
trend that I noticed is seven interior
offensive linemen were taken in the top
39 picks so if you if you do the math
then from the big 12 or the pac-12 no I
don't think so right no just SEC Big Ten
and AC thing ACC yeah but I I kind of
looked at him I was like man that's like
one had a very five picks it was an
interior offensive lineman and I feel
like there was us like a thing about
three years ago which was like there's
not enough value there for a guard it's
a guard you can get a guard later but
Frank rag now the kid from Ohio State
Billy price Isaiah when Isaiah win the
Patriots and then a number two of the
top three picks of the second round
three of the top four right three of the
top four right so I mean quit Nelson of
course so I look at all that and I go
gee we see all of these pass rushers
coming the interior and then I think
about the Tampa Bay Bucs and we go why
didn't they take Derwin James and I go
oh well because they have Gerald McCoy
and V to VII and they play in a division
that faces Jameis Winston Drew Brees and
Matt Ryan how do you mess those guys up
yeah probably go right up their face
right instead of on the outside right
and so for me I think the way and those
teams can run it too it's not like
they're just passing team so you got to
be big up front and match it so the way
that I look at the NFL it's a revolving
door of themes and we go through this
all the time athletic tight ends or
super big right now slot corners are
super big and I think right now an
interior pass rush is enormous and so
the the
that's how the league works and then the
goal is in my mind if you're a GM is to
find a way to go against the grain right
while also being protected against the
grain and that's what billet checks
always done well but just a trend that I
saw in this trip I thought was
interesting I think it is interesting I
think I mean I you said it before the
draft and I think you know in the few of
the conversations and I think you're
spot on but that just to talk about the
interior offensive line and how
important defensive tackles are in the
NFL right now how freakish they are
really ever been better they've never
been better so the Lions trading up to
get a DeSean hand right like a little
bit later in the draft there's not a lot
of guys that are that big no I mean I
get that you know he was another guy if
he didn't have an injury okay with his
knee in college he was a top 40 of the
draft type town when he was healthy
there are special things they like about
the Sean Ham I mean when I turn on the
film and saw the knee good I was
impressed me 6-4 297 ran for 83 I mean
he ran faster than the number one pick
in the draft and only outweighs them by
90 pounds man so that it just tells you
what kind of a 31 and a half inch
vertical at that size 20 H benchpress 28
benchpress reps look we talked a lot
about I talked about at the final four
quarterback right look at the final four
defensive lines hmm the Jacksonville
Jaguars the Philadelphia Eagles the
Minnesota Vikings and then the Patriots
were the ones that were a little bit
small right but they're they have Bell
Belichick Bill Belichick and they have
like it's not a defensive line they have
like a plethora of linebackers and mixed
matches and everything they can do I
watch the Eagles in the eight weeks
where Ronald Darby was hurt playing with
with Jalen Mills and like a cast of
random corners and they never got taken
advantage of yeah and I kept thinking
how is this possible because the d-line
was non-stop you went in the game of the
trenches you've heard that a million
times
alright let's go to guys that fell bit
further than we thought okay and the
surprises that were picked so we'll
start off with us to a fall let's go
with Derwin James yeah at 17 right we
thought he was a lock for 12th what do
you think happened well I think really
the quarterback thing through things
threw a wrench into the situation
Tampa Bay trading down okay they go by
the video right so now the Raiders in
one of the surprises took Colton Miller
yes right which I understand when you
think back about it now and listen they
have a needed tackle that that's the
serious issue there and this was the
second best tackle in the draft and they
just wanted to feel that was a little
too early for Colt Miller probably
here's your second best technology as a
true tackle potential left tackle guy
yet but no he's got a lot of things I
mean he's a starting left tackle at some
point in the NFL he really is but I
think with the Derwin James thing to
okay everybody we heard the people with
the hate mail to Jason light in Tampa
you hear all that stuff right you know I
know the guy you know plumbers are now
should be running the draft but
meanwhile the Bucs had a really good
awesome draft German James doesn't
necessarily fit what they want to do
they're not at like safety in the box
type of team and they have quan
alexander and Levante david who were
like basically big safeties or smaller
linebackers that's what German James is
I mean he's gonna be playing that kam
chancellor position for the Los Angeles
chargers gonna be in the box it's almost
like an extra linebacker so it wasn't
needed there
the next team that you said oh maybe the
Redskins will take him well Doron Payne
was there right I'm not mad at them for
taking to Ron Payne
I mean they weren't desperate at safety
they have no star there but they had
solid there there by the way just on the
Bucks
yeah they got that MJ kid from North
Carolina and Stewart who's kind of a
safe he's gonna be a safety and they
took Carlton Davis man so they addressed
it yes but the Raiders traded back and
as you said took Colton Miller yeah the
other team they were thinking about the
Niners but they went tackle yeah and
then the Dolphins they went make if it's
Patrick the other safety yes they did
and I think they went with the guy that
they just felt like could do the most
and was the safest bit bet a bet for the
back end again gentleman James you
almost have to think of him now does it
he wasn't going to be in the back end
playing centerfield free safety Verdean
it's almost like gotta think he's gonna
be used like at Tel Dan Smith and the
undersized linebacker who could fly
around the field so apparently I read an
article about this the decision for the
Chargers at 17 yeah was Derwin James or
Taven Brian and they really wanted Tevan
Brian but they knew the Jaguars one at
Aven Brian and they were gonna try and
trade up ahead of the Jaguars later too
that also take to even on the man but
they weren't able to do that what same
defensive system of course they both
like that guy because Damon Brian if you
tell him to own a gap he is going to own
it he is a JJ Watt ish
Michael Bennett [ __ ] the play up kind
of player I was surprised when he came
on the screen he was white I didn't know
oh that's great I'm so glad yeah that's
why I was comparing the JJ Watt and some
of the preachers that now I don't go why
I don't crossover no you have of course
that's but that's why this is truly his
movements were JJ Watt nish like I
really looked at it was like sometimes
it does it is similar like he's he was
one of my favorite players in the draft
Jermaine Edmonds fell to 16 yes and
Buffalo actually traded its seemingly
more to get him that I did to trade up
yes yes why do you think Jermaine
Edmonds fell I again I think when we
just look at some of the teams right I
mean okay who's there I in the top ten
really the only team that I was looking
to take linebackers were the Colts and
the Bears right
and the Bears took roll quad right and
the Colts Nelson so that was hard for
them to turn down the Bears obviously
microklen Niners were the team that I
think all of these guys were linked to
yes Tremayne right during roqua
McGlinchey right and they went
McGlinchey and then there was just a run
there was a run you mean the Dolphins
okay I think Minko went higher than
Charmaine and the most moxtra main was
going higher than Minka I would yeah
probably buy a few pics you're right but
then after that you know listen I mean
the Saints they don't need it they
wanted the Marcus Davenport the Raiders
were another team we said who they could
use a linebacker but they won cold
miller and then there they are pick
sixteen I mean damn he got
superfreak that is a middle linebacker
there's gonna be amazing we talked about
some of those teams seeing a Baker
Mayfield and being less than impressed
with his physical attributes yeah the
Buffalo team is gonna go out there this
is a buffalo team that made the playoffs
and they get Josh Allen walking into
practice and they're going holy crap I
mean he might like throw the ball out of
the stadia right and then on defense
Tremayne Edmonds walks up and they go
timeout this absolute specimen is 19
years old like getting a guy of that
athletic ability on
the sides of the ball I don't know if
Josh Islands gonna pan out I'm not as
confident as you are but man that's just
to walk in on the first day you gotta be
feeling there are two guys you're right
they're gonna make you feel warm and
cozy about oh we picked two studs yeah
we don't know what the hell they're
gonna be but they look good in their
uniform and that's a good start but yeah
Edmonds is amazing Edmonds the only
knock like we talked about during the
draft is just the fact that you'd like
to see him maybe be a hair more of a
sledgehammer but I'm not necessarily so
scared about it I he's plenty physical
he's a true linebacker make it more of a
sludge and he definitely isn't he's 19
he just turned 19 I would bet you that
if he tried to grow a beard he couldn't
connect his sideburns to his chin yeah
he might not look smooth you're right
Harold Landry fell to 41 which was the
classic case of a guy that we don't
realize is having a medical issue yep
but the NFL knows but 41 I mean it's
kind of like when Tennessee they took
Kevin Dodd in the second round yeah
that's right Oh maybe that'll be the guy
right he's been okay
yeah but Landry has the been if the
medicals can check out Landry can be a
star Landry can be a like leader of
sacks in the NFL type of guy off the
edge that's what I think everybody likes
about Harold Landry the medical things
yeah that's that's the crappy thing it
the two crappy things about our job are
this when you do the draft is you don't
always know the medical stuff and then
you don't get to see some of the back
end offensive linemen on the team to go
are they content with that backup guard
he mean he didn't play this year but oh
you're trouble for the NF is just
evaluating right that's the two things
like so when you do the draft like you
never know the medical issues like I
didn't know that about Harold Landry
until the day of the the slide yeah and
then yeah you never know how a team
feels about their depth on their
offensive line because you don't always
get to see that you can see maybe a few
preseason snaps and that's it but yeah
man Landry for this defense Dean pees I
mean this this could be their Terrell
Suggs
and then Shekinah Griffin it was in the
fourth round that was amazing III fought
back tears for real I did for sure
seeing him and his brother and what dad
embracing it was amazing amazing why was
it so why did that impact I tell them
it's impacted me talking about it look
at you I know the I guess what impacts
me is
just to the fact that he get to live his
dream and the fact that I mean yeah he's
missing a hand and he's still in the NFL
and you know I do think it was like why
did the NFL invite them that screwed up
to me where I just go and made him sick
made him sit in the greenroom why
because this is what happened and at
least in my estimation the NFL calls
teams they go where do you have this guy
ranked and if they're ranked in the top
50 they go oh we're gonna invite him to
the draft and I bet you they called
everybody and they were like well
Shakima Griffin's one of the top 50
players in the draft but they needed to
ask the follow-up question is but yeah
are you gonna draft a guy with one hand
in the first two rounds that would had
to be the follow-up question they didn't
ask that so instead he had to sit in the
green room for a day for no reason but
yet that was special man and then to go
to a team with his brother I mean the
freaking kid wasn't invited to the
combine but like looking back on it I
didn't really understand how talented he
was until I watched film I mean I don't
even know how that's possible why I mean
you don't invited one of the most
explosive defensive players in football
to the combine why just cuz he's missing
a hand I mean that was crazy too but
yeah that was special that's a cool
moment and I like that ya know it's
interesting to see which storylines the
rest of the world picks up you know cuz
we're sitting there going can you
believe Derwin James fell and people are
going I don't know who Durand James is
but like woody like our makeup artist
came in here was like that Shekinah
Griffon like what a story and then
someone came up to me like I woke up
today to my girlfriend going have you
heard of the Shaq Griffin kid with one
hand he's just it's a little bit like
James Conner last year where he bought
fought against cancer Yeah right and he
was the number one selling jersey I
could see the Griffin Jersey she by the
way sequin Barkley broke the record for
births best-selling Jersey and NFL draft
history Wow I could see she keen Griffin
overtaking that because it's just you
want to rock that guys about it but
another one was the the the 6 8 345
rugby player that went to the Eagles and
I got people going what do think about
this rugby kid I was like well seeing as
how he went in the seventh round not
much and I'll talk to you when he plays
but you know people they want to talk
about him and I'm like you know what
about Josh sweat they're like yeah but
the 16 yeah but that's the mainstream
story right or the in-depth story right
rugby players they're gonna be in for a
world of it's a word since its is it the
playbook
it's the playbook which you heard today
right here like one of the rugby players
like man the pro don't play books what's
gonna really mess you but also a lot of
the times those guys are yeah I see who
they're up against exactly right so now
they're going oh damn you got four
there's ten of me on this team
yes there's 12 of these guys in the
locker room just like me so it's it's
all of a sudden he loses his confidence
over I was the big man on the block and
he goes well [ __ ] Aaron Donald's half my
size and he's pushing me around
everywhere that's the same time though
that's what seventh round picks are for
yes that's right you may hit gold that
and guys with questionable character
past yeah and you get like a jail in
Mills all right Eagles Jalen Mills in
the seventh round right
speaking of contracts
I just wanna this is funny to me Jimmy G
and Richard Sherman have some
interesting things in their contracts
that they're not allowed to do skydiving
hang gliding rocker mountain climbing
racing of any Klein kind including as a
driver or passenger motorcycling use of
any off-road or all-terrain vehicle
professional wrestling right boxing
firearms scuba diving jet skiing surfing
wow Angie's jump diving diving and snow
or waterskiing
they're not allowed to do it yeah would
you be able to give up all of that for
an insane amount of money is there
anything in there that you would have a
trouble giving out and down not at all
because Kyle would do that crap so he's
probably like Mama's I would do that so
let me make them sign this so they don't
do it most players no no I I mean I've
never skied right I not a water-ski a
little I never snow skied I have no idea
and I mean a lot of times like my black
friends they didn't even mess with crap
like that they're like what you're crate
you're going down that hill of those
skis get the hell out of here are you
doing that crap I can't do anything we
just skip this she came Griffin on the
Seahawks yeah where do you think he
plays how do you think they can use it I
think he is going to I think he's gonna
go to the kam chancellor spot you know
nothing he's gonna start there right
away but I think that's the kind of guy
he is
yeah he's 6 1 to 27 he's he's a little
smaller than kam chance
exactly right let him fly around the
field he'll definitely get on the field
and special teams so that's gonna be the
first place where he's gonna be
he's like the Tasmanian devil man when
you watch him on film it's just like
this who is this little crap running
around everywhere hitting everybody well
the thing that really excites me is you
said man the one guy I said Sims who's
the one player that when you watch you
go how the heck is no one talking about
him and we jokingly called it the Carl
Lawson position for guys that are gonna
blow up because for some reason we're
not paying attention and he gets drafted
by the Eagles Josh sweat well I already
put out a video of you talking about him
last time being like I see a lot of
Jadeveon Clowney I see superstar traits
yeah the Eagles are already kind of
flush at guys that get after the past
right this is a this is up your butt Joe
boo pick for them because they were like
huh we got a we got to starting NFL
defensive linemen but we had this super
freak on the board at four and we can if
his knee doesn't hold up we can waste it
we don't care but he might end up being
the best pass rusher in football I mean
that's really what he is yeah I mean
again I'm gonna use my six five to fifty
one four five three I mean play tested
he had the same broad jump as Jadeveon
Clowney yeah the same almost everything
except he had a better vertical that are
for a thirty nine and a half inch
vertical injury though is that his leg
almost had to be amputated as like a
high school right he was coming out of
high school he's one of the freakiest
guys came he's I think he was like what
the number one prospects and being
recruited but yeah I I of course saw him
at the combine I turned on the film and
I was like how could this guy not get
sacks what is the deal here well you
know it's hard to get sacks when you're
a 251 pounds at tackle and the ACC and
and and forget that he's 251 it's like
they played him addy tackle and he was
like one of the most powerful interior
lime and I watched on film he lined up
over tackles and would push them back
more than some of the second and third
round defensive tackles he is a freak of
nature
oh you should be because as long as he
is just somewhat healthy I mean he could
be superstar plus if he falls the
motivation in this kid yeah he's in
there with Michael Bennett and Fletcher
Cox and learn all these little tricks of
the trade how to use this
I mean everything he's in the perfect
spot for a guy like this I Philadelphia
is the perfect culture for any rookie
yeah come in there and it's just like we
had guys that talk crap we have leaders
in the community we have people if you
like God you can go over and hang out
carson wentz right whatever you need we
got it in this locker room so your top
five right now in Power Rankings we're
gonna end here okay number five you have
the Vikings yes
number four you have the Jaguars yes
number three the New England Patriots
you know they are the number one team in
ads in Vegas number two you have the
Warriors you're gonna make me pick like
oh you have to bet a million dollars
right now yeah to the Rams and number
one the Eagles yes anything surprise I
thought you maybe you'd have the joy I
am gonna check I don't know if the Rams
I'm ranking offseason and draft and
draft and the team that they had in
place compared to last year a little bit
I'm trying to take all the new it
account
yeah the Rams I mean I'm just seeing a
huge hole in the middle of the Rams
defense right now yeah and that's I
don't think anyone's taking that into
account
yeah I get that they have safety play
they got mark Baron you know and they
have more than enough safeties on the
roster so here you'll treat did for that
team last I know and I think people are
sorry they're gonna sleep on it they're
gonna realize it when they watch the
Giants play I add a lot of Giants fans
coming up to me and saying it's funny
we're drafting positions that we've
neglected for so long right the the
offensive guard trading for the
linebacker getting a pass rusher yes
well and I think too with your old
latrine thing I think the interesting
there that I'll be watching because this
is the one thing people like Aaron
Donald dirt up the field team so they
let up people who run up the middle and
a little bit like Pittsburgh with Ryan
shazier when you're that aggressive yes
sometimes guys trip and fall or shoot up
the field too hard to miss the miss the
guy as he's going by and shaved here was
the trash cleaner and we saw like when
he was in there like well this Steelers
defense isn't the same I do think that
could happen with the Rams I'm just
realizing this right now yeah I'm going
to have to do it live on the air we need
to figure out what our battle is going
to be on Wednesday yeah so I'm gonna
pull up the list that I had from before
and I'm
gonna have you pick a number one through
something okay so let me let me figure
out one through something it's a battle
royale of course I don't know it up
between the Colts and the Broncos
alright so I'm gonna edit this in a
second let me find this bad boy do you
see that video that I sent you of Paul
Brown vs. the dolphin I knew that was
awesome
can you a dolphin jumping up and
smacking a human like that that was good
it didn't hurt the guy that was a good
thing okay
dolphin okay here we go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 1 through 8 Sims this will be our
battle pick a number one through eight
oh I'm going number two versus two
number two this one comes out comes us
comes to us from m'kay Cat Rescue and
the battle that we will be doing do you
want one or two of the two things
the first one of the second one which he
has two things you're saying it's
something versus something do you with
the first or the second I want the first
you will be representing a patriot and I
will be representing a Buccaneer so
coming up on Wednesday we will be doing
a patriot versus a Buccaneer Sims will
be a patriot I will be a buck you're
dead I'm dead you're dead
yo pour out some tea I got a musket you
got a sword you're screwed as hell I've
got a cannonball and our judge of course
will be big phil simms did big Phil you
talked to him both a giraffe oh yeah a
little bit certainly yeah yeah yeah we
talked a lot we'll see what he I don't
even know all his big takeaways well
let's we'll get him on here on Wednesday
and see what the big blowhard has to say
yeah well I want to end as we leave if
you want to watch our full draft
coverage go to youtube and we have all
of the pics there one through ten 11
through 20 21 through 32
always thank you for subscribing if
you're listening to us on any way that
you listen to podcasts thank you guys so
much and I want to end you one more time
with the sultry sounds of Jim Irsay tell
your friends out there what's up pals
love you guys talk to you soon force in
peace out homies ventric says good
evening and the lef koe man says what's
up quittin how you doing pal let's go
drag take some drags you guys later in
my class bye